[Musique]
enfin les enfants bonsoir ce que je suis
content patron pourquoi nounours mais
deux petits amis sont sages ce soir ils
le font pas de bruit ils sont sûrement
en train de travailler ces chers petits
je descends les voir ou les châles
europe à
propos
[Musique]
au maire vous avez l'air sage
ce que vous êtes sur le
net à notre avis commission mam a déjà
écrit il nous a collés la cause et nous
lui disons qu'on arrive très bientôt
voilà une excellente nouvelle
[Musique]
eh ben tu va nous aider à les caissettes
elle prend un crayon rouge qu'est-ce que
je suis
bien content de venir jouer avec toi
j'apporterai ma poupée caprice avec toi
georges moi mon cerveau alors des blue
jays thoune est super
comment nous acheter ou louer
une pour tata alors dit oui est ce que
maman pourra monter tient mais cette
jolie auto dans la lettre ça lui ferait
plaisir ce n'est pas possible nicolas
pas dans une loge elle la tient sedin a
une image d'accord ou non alors si tu
m'as l'image qui met aussi le dos pauvre
de moi pas d'imagés pas d'automobile je
termine en disant grande et c'est signé
de très belles salut mais dallas a mis
ses très sincères chère petite amie
ainsi qu'à tes parents et les bons gènes
est alors respect à tata et voilà ouf
quel est le temps à long ou hst au lui
demain ça peut me dire d'aller dormir
ouste au mois n'oublie pas d'envoyer
notre lettre soyez sans inquiétude je
vais l'expédier art express
bonne nuit le petit
c'est vrai
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants allez vite vous
coucher à trous partout but que se
passe-t-il nounours une lettre urgente
apporté à la poste une lettre express on
y va
dépêchons-nous bonne nuit les enfants
couchés vous bien sagement est fait pour
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]